hey everybody welcome to another hg
tutorial and this one as you can see i
have a title is going to be how to
download and install internet explorer 8
to upgrade your current version of
internet explorer so just to show you
guys that i currently have the version
of internet explorer
that you may be using right now i'm
going to try to find ie7
in my uh my rocket dock to the left
so here we go um i've i currently have
internet explorer version seven and in
order to find out what version you have
you can tell number one by the look of
it and number two just by going i
believe um i'm guessing here to tools
and
something about internet options and
that'll probably give you some
information about your web browser
but basically i just want to let you
guys know that i do have internet
explorer 8 and i'm going to be showing
you guys in this tutorial how to upgrade
to in i have i'm sorry i have internet
explorer seven and i'm showing you guys
in this tutorial how to upgrade to ie8
so here we go i'm just going to open up
safari for the purpose of this download
and i actually already have uh the link
to this in my in my clipboard here so
i'm just going to paste it into safari
it really doesn't matter what web
browser you use to download it because
installation is a breeze so here we go
this is the internet explorer 8 home
page it is completely out of beta and
this is the full on brand new version of
an internet explorer eight and right
right here on the front of their site is
the download now button and that's all
we're gonna do
i'm just i'm gonna definitely have some
more reviews about ie8 later to come but
this is definitely just the installation
video i'll make it a response to my
safari 4 beta video so here we go first
of all if you're a windows 7 user you
have to do
follow these steps if you're windows of
your other operating system user you
have to select your operating system so
i have my windows vista so i'm just
going to click on it and now it's going
to ask me to choose my language so first
i'm just going to obviously my language
is english
and scroll down hit the download button
when you hit that button this little
window right here will come up security
running warning just hit run is a 13.3
megabyte download and it's pretty fast
because it's coming from microsoft to a
windows machine
so there the 13 megabytes is done
downloading and we're going to wait for
a little pop-up window to come up here
and
meanwhile i'm going to actually i'm
going to exit out of safari before i run
the installer
all right here's the installer right
here we're just going to hit the run
button to run the installer and i'm
going to exit out of my web browser in
the background so we can give full uh
full memory to
this um or full memory uh priority to
the installation process so here we go
it says welcome to internet explorer
eight and before you begin begin it says
we recommend that you save your files
and close all programs so i'm going to
just save this i'm not going to close
everything
um ie8 as simple as that so we're going
to do is just hit the next button it's
very simple installation you have to
accept everything that they tell you and
is to install updates so just hit next
and i'm i'm not going to what let have
you guys watch the entire thing but
basically it's going to download it's
going to install internet explorer 8
it'll install all the updates necessary
in case there's an earlier or a later
version and it's going to finish the
setup clean up all the temporary files
and i'll probably launch internet
explorer eight so i'll bring you guys
back to the screen uh when it is done
installing internet explorer eight and
i'll get back to you
all right ladies and gentlemen i went
downstairs and left the installer run
and i came back upstairs and this is the
screen that greeted me and it says
internet explorer was installed without
the latest windows updates to install
them restart your computer so i'm going
to restart later for the purpose of
finishing uh this tutorial
and um that's basically all you need to
know i'll restart my computer and show
you guys what windows or internet
explorer 8 looks like and that'll be the
end so thanks for watching peace